[Music]
[Applause]
most boys do want to do the initiation
it's not about looking beautiful it's an
initiation process it's about becoming
part of the community and it's about
becoming a real saving man I'm not
really sure what will happen when I go
inside the man house no matter what
happens I will be strong and I will go
through it I will change now I am only a
little bit of an adult but after I go
inside I will be a whole man people is
beaten my not anything obviously scared
they're nervous they also know that they
are not going to see their family their
mother's two younger sisters their
younger brothers for a very long time so
they just don't really know what's going
to happen to them the bottom line is
that the initiates are treated as
females even in their own language they
refer to as wives the women are
obviously worried about their kids they
know what's going to happen to their
boys they have seen this initiation
process every year and they know that
their boys are going to be cut to pieces
I wonder if our boys are going to be
okay when they cut the skin and I know
what only listen like blowing on it
would be bad if we lose their lives our
find it very hard in there I worry about
that the men might tell us that they are
okay on the man house but I cannot go
and see it with my own eyes if they cut
my skin and then I got up and they
washed me I felt very weak and I had to
lie down on the ground
because the boys are cut all over their
body they cut on their arms on their
chest on their backs down their legs
there's not really much they can do and
the only time they really get up is to
go to the bathroom or to eat three times
they don't assume now that it's done it
hurts to sit down when you lie down to
sleep your chest and your belly hurt
the initiation process is actually quite
a long process it will go over weeks the
humiliation is part of this process and
is repeatedly done to these boys almost
on a daily basis it's to remind them of
authority it's to put them into their
place that it was idioms in there was a
lot of blood but I tried to stay strong
during the cutting the initiation is
finished now and I have become a new man
[Applause]